[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi à 18 juin
au week-end très musical vous attend
dans le département fête de la musique
oblige les communes organise de nombreux
rendez vous autour de cet art deuxième
participation pour le collège de la mare
au sol et deuxième victoire les
canadiens ont remporté vendredi la
dernière édition du concours
intercollèges de match d'improvisation
et les passionnés d'histoire ont été
servis pendant trois jours le musée
d'archéologie ouvert son village des
savoir-faire en découvrant des
techniques ancestrales
il fêtait ses 20 ans vendredi dernier le
cycliste le championnat inter collèges
de match d'improvisation de théâtre
piloté par déclic théâtre et quatre
établissements scolaires de
l'agglomération s'affronter pour le
titre
retour sur cette soirée avec michael
jarry libre ugsel berger et romane russe
pini ils sont donc les vainqueurs de ce
20è asik mythe
il s'agit bien sûr de l'équipe de la
barousse
[Applaudissements]
le trophée last à coignières pour la
deuxième année consécutive la mare au
sol remporté le concours intercollèges
d'improvisation le match était super
cool hésiter qu'elle et ses autres
équipes étaient super forte et on
s'attendait pas du tout à être en finale
et les match était très serré où on est
resté dans le jeu à fond et puis et puis
c'est vraiment à la fin l'effet de
surprise on s'y attendait pas forcément
et on est super heureux parce que basse
et en plus c'est la deuxième année du
coup j'ai pas eu grand chose à faire en
vrai un mois je m'asseyais dans une
salle et je la regardais jouer ça
suffisait largement ils se sont tous
très bons il ya un très bon groupe mais
ça reste très important et là
franchement ce soir je pense que les
quatre équipes étaient hyper homogène ça
a donné des très belles rencontres
une victoire obtenue face à une coriace
équipe orr pas yens le collège alexandre
dumas s'incline 3 quant à 4 comme si ma
dernière année j'ai kiffé j'aurais pas
je remets ça dure plus longtemps mais
comme d'habitude bas
honnêtement j'ai bien aimé cette finale
franchement même les demi-finales des
touristes et sympathique où qu'on soit
2e 4e ou quoi l'important c'est qu'on
s'est bien amusé et de l'improvisation
compter à la création chanter les quatre
collèges en compétition dû rivaliser
d'imagination devant les thèmes imposés
j'étais bien avec mon chien je vais
chercher le fusil du soir le podium est
complété par le collège des prés à
montigny le bretonneux cette année 14
collèges sont affrontés tout au long de
l'année des rencontres pour désigner un
vainqueur qui vise la passe de trois
pour la prochaine édition du 19 au 30
juin le cinéma les yeux d'elsa de
saint-cyr-l'ecole veux vous mettre des
étoiles plein les yeux
pour cette 9e édition de la comédie du
frisson du patrimoine des films venant
d'un peu partout à travers le monde
puisque vous pourrez découvrir des
métrages sénégalais et brésiliens amont
avec le responsable du cinéma avant de
regarder un extrait du roi et l'oiseau
un mythe de l'animation française
on souhaite que les gens viennent passer
des moments en famille avec leurs
enfants entre grands-parents et
petits-enfants dans cette salle de
cinéma pour partager et construire des
souvenirs ensemble
[Musique]
je
mais j'ai pas peur des enfants ma parole
à des trous
mais
toutes les dates et séances sont
disponibles sur le site internet de la
commune le 21 juin c'est la 38e fête de
la musique a rendez vous incontournable
pour de nouveaux os commune yvelinoise
certaines font durer le plaisir en
proposant leur rendez vous le samedi 22
juin voire le dimanche 23 jan et c'est
le quoi le cas pardon des trois communes
représentées par nos invités marie
pierre d'une au président de
l'association l'art en tête à magny les
hameaux qui propose un solstice d art
benjamin bolland directeur du
développement social et culturel des
clayes-sous-bois qui organise des clés
si belle et brice martin le responsable
de l'école de musique de guyancourt
bonjour à tous les trois benjamin voilà
on va commencer avec vous puisque au
clae souvent en attaque dès 15 heures au
parc de diane
et oui mais oui mais qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent c'est de 15h jusqu'à un peu plus
de minuit
voilà donc on commence dès l'après-midi
à la fois avec eux avec des groupes
tremplin on appelle ça certains groupes
qui se sont qualifiés depuis deux ans
pour avoir le plaisir de jouer sur une
mission une très grande scène voilà en
première votre rythme longtemps avant
très longtemps à l'avant soit là
pour les plus anciens deux ans à l'avant
si l'on passé des des sélections avec
des jurys populaires là et puis il
arrive la clé si belle on démarre on
ouvre le parc à 15 heures la musique
commence à 16 heures voilà donc
s'enchaînent ce qu'on appelle les
musiques live nous tous ces groupes qui
se sont qualifiées vont s'enchaîner donc
on va voir de l'élection a sélectionné
aussi lors de soirées qui ont jalonné la
les saisons antérieures
voilà donc on aura on aura quatre
groupes qualifiés différents qui seront
autour du rock du pop la funk du rap
voilà le ragga voilà des groupes qui
sont qui sont à la fois pour certains en
voie de professionnalisation d'autres
complètement amateur mais tu vois ça
atteint un niveau jugé suffisant en tout
cas pour pouvoir s'exprimer devant à
partir de 16h on est déjà à plus de 5000
de personnes jusqu'à jusqu'à 15000 voilà
au plus haut plus on voit les choses en
grand
oakley souvent même chose du côté de la
batterie est ce que chez vous ces cinq
ex pas scéniques et près de 40 groupes
ont nextel donc vous samedi à 22 juin à
partir de 18h avec une première phase
écoles de musique de 18h à 21h toutes
les classes vont se succéder avec un
final la grande salle de la batterie
la conjuration de la grande guerre et
ensuite effectivement il ya les groupes
amateurs de musiques actuelles qui ont
été sélectionnés choisi et qui vont
pouvoir se produire là alors du côté de
man idéalement on a choisi de mettre
plusieurs arts en avant on en parlera un
petit peu plus tard mais surtout pendant
deux jours ces les styles les gens qui
vont se mêler se croisent et qui vont se
mêler alors moi je suis pas la
présidente de l'are en tête mais je suis
à l'initiative de cet événement soit 6
des arts depuis sept ans qui regroupe
différents arts là cette année
particulièrement beaucoup plus de
musique que les autres années puisque
l'ensemble des associations musicales de
la ville
l'harmonie manie coisy colère des petits
éléments vont venir aussi participer
plus intensément sur les deux jours on
voit la particularité de la fête de la
musique c'est mettre en avant les
talents locaux
amani a eu du recrutement on fait venir
les associations qui sont implantées sur
le territoire
oui oui oui sur le territoire donc donc
là en peinture en sculpture
il y aura donc des choses en dans
l'église avec le l'école de musique de
la mérantaise zic en herbe la bande
magnétique donc ça c'est un petit un
petit groupe une petite ma nation de
l'harmonie monique oise qui va suivre
balade contée on voit là toute la
semaine pour qui des animations toute la
journée toute la pré n'est qu'à des
salles à l'heure dimanche est la forme
magnétique conclura le dimanche 23 juin
alors on a parlé des talents locaux ce
qui pousse mais aux clayes-sous-bois il
ya un clé siens qu'on a découvert en
2016 et que vous invitez ce soir là
vincent vinel il fallait leur faire dire
à ben oui c c c java dire c'est le bébé
du village mais n'ont pas pas vraiment
mais en tout cas c'est voilà c'est un
jeune qui a vraiment une geek les
siennes depuis tout petits qui acquit
qui a vécu aussi dans nos structures et
puis qui est devenu un artiste complet
qui a fait don café the voice à cette
une
c'est une étape mais depuis c'est le
tremplin depuis il a fait du cinéma
voilà et puis on a fait quelques grosses
scènes déjà et puis nous fait ce cadeau
parce que c'est vraiment ça de de venir
se produire dans dans sa ville quoi
c'est à la fois un grand plaisir pour
lui puis c'est vraiment un super cadeau
pour nous que les siens on a hâte
d'entendre en plus il va nous faire des
surprises des nouveaux titres voilà donc
on est ravi il se préserve gilad il a
fait sa propre programmation pour cette
soirée là brice martin chez vous la
plupart des artistes sont issus de
l'école municipale
mais c'est aussi une façon de conclure
l'année exactement puis de renforcer
cette idée que l'école de musique
municipale ou conservatoire pas c'est en
tout cas ce terreau de musiciens
amateurs ou professionnels
peu importe enfin en tout cas cela
cohabitent entre les professeurs les
élèves de tout âge dans tous les styles
et puis ensuite avec les groupes de
musiques actuelles diverses et variées
l'amateur une école de musique on
retrouve aussi à magny les hameaux
oui l'école de musique de la mérantaise
qui
où les jeunes se secoue alors je suis
pas sa surface se forment depuis des
années dans un très beau lieu
blaise pascal
je suis pas spécialisé vélo sociaux des
arts aussi c'est de mettre en avant les
talents de la commune que ça commence
tout petits jusqu'aux plus grands parce
que des élèves peuvent être adulte aussi
bien sûr bien sûr
alors moi je parle du taux de peinture
et du scud alors voilà parce que
j'allais bien c'est que j'ai la
sculpture je m'appelle je voulais en
venir c'est élise et vous vous avez
mêlez vous êtes servis de cette musique
pour amélété will solstice valadares je
voulais que les associés que les gens se
rencontrent je suis art-thérapeute et
donc j'interviens en sculpture en
peinture dans des univers différents
gd public on pourrait qualifier au
d'ordinaire des publics spécifiques et
donc des événements comme ceux-là ils
peuvent se rencontrer
voilà est aussi assez solide oman ici
c'est intéressant de le dire c'est
l'association qui va nous présenter des
jeux de plein air dont les gens pourront
jouer à des jeux surdimensionnés tout
tout ce week end là et toutes ces
associations la cua habitants en font
vraiment vivre la commune et se paie le
voyage parce que ça se passe à magny les
hameaux villages qui est quand même
excentré de
l'amour je vous rends très petit pour
faire voilà que ce que c'est cela aussi
actif dans la ville alors les lézards
temps les artistes locaux par dans les
talents locaux vont pouvoir s'exprimer
mais public batni à contribution chez
vous il y aura des ateliers
oui des ateliers alors des ateliers de
travail du fil de fer en sculpture parce
que la pierre du fil de fer pour les
enfants le samedi après midi le dimanche
après-midi d'aquarelles aussi l'après
midi du samedi à ce que dimanche sont
bons et ceux ci soient légalisés
l'atelier écriture je dis ça aussi les
lectures de l'atelier d'écriture de
manille brice martin vous avez prononcé
un thème tout à l'heure la grande guerre
parce qu'il ya un concert inédit cette
année en hommage quand elle est pensée
c'est par rapport aux musiques d'époque
les instruments d'époque comment il a
été pensé le contexte enfin le point de
départ c'est l'opportunité c'est à dire
que le service des archives et
patrimoine de la ville de bécancour
continue prolonge son exposition sur le
commération de la grande guerre et elle
trimballe cette exposition de maisons de
quartier en quartier et le final ce sera
dans des expositions ce soir dans le
hall de l'école de musique voilà moi je
rebondis sur la thématique que j'ai bien
travaillé que je connais bien et j'ai
proposé au professeur de participer de
se greffer là-dessus donc effectivement
oui il y aura toute l'année à partir de
20h à 21h dans la grande salle
on va changer on va chanter on va jouer
des chansons en tout cas qui ont un
rapport plus ou moins directe avec la
hague le thème de la guerre et surtout
d'après guerre les années de
construction il optimise ses des élèves
que vous avez vous avez profité aussi à
sensibiliser sur cette période est tout
à fait tout à fait il avait déjà fait ce
travail et leur maman pendant la période
2014 2018 mais bon là c'est une manière
de conclure au 6 pi 2 2 dead a lancé à
la ville de bécancour le territoire plus
largement que voile à l'école de musique
travaillent ensemble et tous les
enseignants et élèves arrivent à
convaincre sur un projet ensemble
benjamin ball on va finir avec vous
parce que dans votre sang et l'excès
cybèle il ya un groupe qui vient pas du
coin qui a de loin mais peut-être le
point d'orgue de cette soirée un groupe
mythique 13 musiciens repart toiles
célèbres qui avait dont le morceau a été
remis au goût du jour par un certain
trappistes omar sy lorsque l'amf
ailleurs cessé voilà c'est mythique
c'est une grande chance pour les
clayes-sous-bois les accueillir voilà
avec le maquis qui était là lorsque dans
le fire forcément et il a certains qui
sont morts mais en tout cas le maquis
qui est à l'origine du groupe à
reconstituer tout un collectif qui nous
fait revivre
je presque presque mieux qu'en vrai
voilà tous les titres là mais faut pas
oublier aussi hk hk juste à voir ce que
nous fûmes fire hk et les saltimbanks
voilà devenu hk lempire de papier voilà
qui est aussi un groupe de festivals
absolument incroyable reggae ragga qui
sait mettre une ambiance absolument
voilà phénoménal donc c'est vrai que la
soirée va être être très animé très fun
très très dansante très joyeuse palais
nous aussi on a des ateliers dans le
monde partout les gens profitent les
enfants qui sont les bienvenus et tout
un tas de l'animation dans ce qu'on
appelle le village en musique où ils
peuvent essayer des instruments
construire voilà il est vraiment on fait
des animations pour les plus petits
jusqu'aux plus grands jusqu'à
l'apothéose de l'arrivée des lorsqu'il
fallut renouvelle tout droit des
états-unis là qui viennent d'atterrir il
ya une semaine à loin et qui passe par
les quais sous bois et donc tout ça ça
donne envie va falloir faire un choix
merci à tous les droits d'être revenue
sur ce plateau les programmations sont
de vos rendez vous sont à retrouver sur
les sites des communes respectives ce
que bien sûr on n'a pas pu tout dire
et il ya d'autres rendez vous sur le
département vous en doutez bien à saint
germain en laye les festivités débutent
à 16 heures avec de la musique bretonne
du rock et de la variété française à
voisins le bretonneux les écoles ans
l'événement avec leurs chorales seront
suivies de la scène ouverte à poissy la
fête de la musique est partout dans les
brasseries les bars et restaurants de
20h30 à minuit et à la collégiale de 18h
à 23h à croissy-sur-seine vous partez
pour les états unis la ville s'inspire
de la venue de l'équipe de football
féminine américaine pour célébrer la
culture du côté de maurepas les
terrasses vont s'animer toute la soirée
et du côté de l'ue vs cul ou double le
plaisir avec deux rendez-vous les
ensembles tribu les simone des
personnels de l'uv est ce qu sont en
concert sur les pauses déjeuner et 20 et
24 juin ou par à guyancourt où on reste
à guyancourt jusqu'au mois de juin
l'honneur est en talents locaux théâtre
musique et arts plastiques jusqu'au 25
juin la salle d'exposition de la ville
regroupe près de 200 oeuvres tout juste
sorti des ateliers de la commune audrey
chaillou pour les images
le travail de toute une année plus de
150 artistes présentent des oeuvres tout
droit sortis de leurs ateliers des
artistes un peu particulier ils sont
tous amateurs et pratique au sein
d'associations bihan courtoise
on peut voir donc nos artistes enfants
qui évolue d'année en année qu'on voit
grandir devenir des adolescents
développer leur pratique améliorer leur
technique
et puis apprendre à nos adultes convoi
s'essayer à différentes techniques on me
laisse libre cours aux associations
d'exposer leurs artistes
donc ils choisissent ils ne choisissent
pas chaque artiste expose jusqu'à deux
oeuvres ces deux oeuvres sont présentées
telles qu'elles donc on a vraiment pas
de sélection qui est effectué et ça
permet de laisser libre cours aux
artistes et qu'on pouvoir exposer ce
qu'il souhaite
des oeuvres personnelles et d oeuvre
collective regroupant toutes les
techniques travaillées durant l'année
certains de ces artistes ont attiré le
regard des sélectionneurs d'art talent
le concours d'arts visuels de la commune
la règle est en cours cet angle est
universel ça devrait être partout pareil
d'ailleurs est donc tout le monde peut y
trouver sa place les amateurs comme les
professionnels et ce sont ces amateurs
qui au travers des associations font
vivre et insuffle ce dynamisme la ville
tout au long de l'année
huit associations ont répondu présent
cette année leurs adhérents présents
très de 200 oeuvres pour une exposition
toute en légèreté
[Musique]
et pour ce qui est du théâtre direction
la ferme de bel ébat du 20 au 23 juin la
salle grouille guillon courtoise
accueille six représentations des
troupes amateurs
toute la programmation est disponible
sur le site internet de la ville le
palais du roi de rome est un musée
joyeux un titre qu'il a acquis à en
adhérant à la charte de l'association
momar une association loi 1901 créée
pour aider les sites culturels à
améliorer leur accueil et leur service
pour les familles le musée rambolitains
a souscrit audi droit à des petits
visiteurs proposant ainsi des activités
pour les familles autorisant le carnet à
dessins ou encore autorisant les
poussettes
on vous propose maintenant de flâner
comme les excursionnistes et les prendre
présage east du 19e siècle
ils vous invitent à un pique nique au
petit moulin des vaux de cernay au coeur
du parc naturel naturel de la haute
vallée de chevreuse et on en parlait que
notre nouvel invité pascal camus bonjour
vous êtes chargé d événementiel open en
deux roues alors ce rendez vous c'est
une plongée au coeur du 19e siècle tout
à fait puisque en fait on a préparé des
différentes saynètes tout au long de la
journée
c'est un événement qui commence de 11
heures jusqu'à 17 heures 10 terminera
par un bal champêtre et tout au long de
la journée différentes animations sont
proposées pour tous les publics
on a pensé également aux enfants avec
des petits ateliers dessin est ce que
justement on va pas seulement peindre ou
parler de peinture nom va être reproché
à l'époque l'idée c'est justement c'est
de se replonger dans les pubs de flâner
de prendre de prendre le temps de jouer
avec ses enfants de retourner un petit
peu dans le passé à travers différents
outils les outils d'antan pour les
grands enfin pour les adultes qui sont
intéressés par le sujet une ouverture
gratuite aussi aux petits moulins qui
est un musée qui est gérée par le parc
naturel de la haute vallée de chevreuse
et qui avait tellement est payant donc
là une entrée libre
voilà tout à fait vous pourrez donc
admirer enfin
plutôt visiter voir un petit peu ce qui
avait été fait à l'époque avec les
peintres paysagistes et aussi en ce qui
concerne les petits blé ou des moulins
au regard c'est la troisième édition wii
le public aime remonter le temps faim
succès oui tout à fait parce que c est
en plein air c'est dans un endroit
bucolique qui était d'ailleurs un lieu
où les peintres mais se retrouver mais
donc le public également aujourd'hui
c'est à côté de l'abbaye des vaux de
cernay de la cascade des vaux de cernay
donc il ya un petit parc enfin il ya un
petit parc près de la forêt en fait vous
avez différents panneaux sur la géologie
du lieu également enfin plein
d'activités autour du petit moulin
donc c'est une visite tout à fait
intéressante et notamment pour les
parisiens qui prendront un petit peu
d'air frais alors savait pas nîmes et
sète
est ce que ce sont les équipes du pnr
qui sont en costume ou est-ce qu'on fait
venir des peintres de l'époque part de
divers par des associations way est là
il ya plusieurs choses il ya une
compagnie dont qui va organiser un petit
peu les saynètes parce que là il faut
être un petit peu professionnel quand
même nous avons aussi des équipes du
parc qui sera d disait également
et puis tout au lond tout au long de la
journée en fait ça va être un petit peu
plusieurs petites saynètes qui vont se
dérouler on a aussi proposé un peu alors
quelque chose d'un peu plus pour les
ados on va dire un cadre où ils pourront
prendre à celle fille avec des personnes
habillées dans les habits de l'époque un
peu de ma chronique mal an / photo avec
des photos rayonnement c'est ce qu'il
faut il faut un peu le jeu peut choquer
et et quoi d'autre bah y'a plein
d'associations justement qui ont aidé
aussi à la création de ces petits
moulins qui a été ouvert en septembre
2016 donc on a plus en plus de visiteurs
là
dernière pour l'édition des peintres
paysagistes on avait plus de 600
visiteurs
donc c'est quand même un chiffre est
relativement important et fait souvent
des passionnés qui viennent parce qu'on
peut venir costumés si on doit dans
notre document de risque il faut bien
sûr au contraire plus on y costumes et
plus ça permet justement de beuverie
entre guillemets et puis de pouvoir
danser de finir la journée en dansant
avec un bal champêtre donc absolument
est ce qu'aujourd'hui ça attire encore
les peintres oh oui oui tout à fait bien
sûr pas les lieux aussi est unique donc
si vous n'êtes pas venu c'est le moment
de venir
c'est le moment de venir alors ce pique
nique c'est donc dans la
l'agenda la saison on va dire du pnr
c'est ça aussi la haute vallée de
chevreuse on montre ses valeurs ses
talents comme je vais avec nos invités
précédente affaire tout à fait puisque
non nous avons un site internet donc je
me permets de donner ses ww point parc
tiré du site naturel tiré du sichon
breuses point fr et justement l'idée
c'est que tous les habitants du
territoire puisse trouver des
manifestations à proximité de chez eux
parce que nombre de choses qui se
passent sur le territoire que ce soit
dans l'art dans la culture à travers des
dessins des expositions des concerts que
les toits qui a une histoire feu eh bien
si on remonte dans l'histoire on remonte
encore dans l'histoire mais également et
maintenant on fait le territoire du parc
naturel nous avons quand même 53 connus
qui sont gérés enfin qui sont gérés qui
sont sous ce faux kreider d'idées du
parc naturel régional de la haute vallée
de chevreuse donc il ya quand même un
intérêt particulier et l'idée justement
c'est promouvoir tous les sites
fantastique quand elles sont notre
territoire pour le faire connaître
je pense que plus on connaît puis on
apprécie également et on organise cet
été des balades aussi pour les pour les
jeunes enfants qui s'appelle la balade
des petits curieux où on l'a on fait
prendre un petit peu contact avec la
nature et c'est important aussi de
connaître la nature qui nous entoure
c'est comme ça qu'on peut mais la
protéger et comme vous adonner site
c'est parfait les gens pourront aller
voir ils ne rateront au carré vous merci
beaucoup parce quelqu'un lui demande à
notre invitation
on le rappelle pour le pique nique des
peintres expression
excursionnistes et paysages et surtout
pardon c'est le dimanche 23 juin à
partir de 11 heures et ça se passe au
petit moulin des vaux de cernay
on était dans l'histoire on continue
mais auront encore un peu les passionnés
ont pu faire un saut dans le temps ce
week-end du 14 au 16 juin c'était les
journées nationales de l'archéologie
trois jours pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir nos ancêtres au musée
d'archéologie nationale de saint germain
en laye où ont misé sur les savoirs
faire ancestraux
gwenaëlle saintilan et nicolas landry un
travail minutieux et délicat pour les
orques et aux log en herbe au musée
d'archéologie nationale de saint germain
en laye en transmettez ce week-end ses
connaissances c'est un village des
savoir-faire donc l'objectif c'est de
permettre au public de re découvrir les
objets qui sont présents depuis plus de
cent cinquante deux ans au musée
d'archéologie nationale mais sous un
angle un peu différent découvrir la
dextérité et savoir-faire des
populations qui les ont précédés un
village créé pour les journées
nationales de l'archéologie le site
yvelinois proposer une trentaine
d'animations comme on peut pas remonter
le temps on ne peut pas savoir comment
les gaulois fabriquer leurs objets en
verre donc on va faire des hypothèses
depuis dix ans jouait le rôle en étudie
les parures envers une technique que les
gaulois ne maîtrise qu au vème siècle
avant notre ère les chercheurs partagent
leurs découvertes
la leçon semble retenue par un jeune
participant il fallait chauffer et un
four à à lui à plus de 850 degré qu'on
faisait des bracelets ensuite quand les
élargi chez pour cette 10e journée le
site accueilli près de 5000 personnes
des découvertes qui ne s'arrête pas au
rendez vous national le masne partage
ses savoirs depuis cent cinquante deux
ans
nous en parlions la semaine dernière
avec nos invités le projet danse à
l'école a fêté cette année ses 20 ans un
dispositif à destination des élèves du
territoire de la maternelle au lycée
et une découverte de la danse
contemporaine avec des rencontres avec
des artistes professionnels des ateliers
et la découverte de spectacles
les participants de cette dernière
édition se sont retrouvés ce week-end à
la commanderie pour présenter le fruit
de leur travail
un retour sur leur expérience au micro
de grégory canale pour présenter une
autre spectre et qu'on a fait pendant un
an presque attendant c'est qu'on n'a pas
râlé de la danse on a tout fait l'isro s
appréciant monsieur n'a pu faire ma
beaucoup de trucs et avant j'étais petit
village fait trop timide à prendre va se
parler se faire des six une seconde voie
pour qu'on se répète une dernière
information avant de nous quitter le
centre des monuments nationaux a
souhaité ouvrir pu la plus largement au
public deux monuments à rambouillet la
laiterie de la reine marie antoinette et
la chaumière aux coquillages sont
dorénavant ouverte en accès libre sur
des créneaux régulier pour les
informations pratiques
direction le site du monument c'est la
fin de cette étude culture merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve mercredi pour
champ pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]